thanks to ground news for helping
support this episode you are traveling
at the speed of light right now though
it might not seem like it maybe you're
sitting in a chair thinking you're at
rest at the fastest you're on a plane
that isn't the speed of light is it the
problem is you're not thinking four-
dimensionally you're only thinking of
your speed through space when you also
have a speed through time if we consider
them both together as a SpaceTime speed
then the speed of all matter including
you and me is the speed of
light hey Gracies what we're talking
about is something called four velocity
which is just short for four-dimensional
velocity but to understand what that is
we're going to need to start in three
dimensions regular old velocity also
known as three velocity is a way to
represent two things
simultaneously how fast something is
moving and in what direction it's moving
that's why we represent it with an arrow
it's the speed and direction it's pretty
straightforward and it's a very useful
way to look at velocity if you never
intend on going Beyond three dimensions
for that we need to think like a
mathematician we're going to generalize
things to death first if we draw the
path we can see the velocity is always
tangent to that path is that like how
you go off on a random train of thought
sometimes actually that tangent uses the
word metaphorically we're using the old
more literal definition tangent comes
from the old Latin word Tanger meaning
to touch in our case velocity is always
along something called a tangent line
that's an imaginary line touching our
path without Crossing it the velocity is
along the tangent line at every point on
the path it's something universally true
of all real velocities everywhere but
that's just the direction though right I
mean what about the speed speed is the
length of the arrow which is is
determined by another rule it's usually
measured in Miles hour or kilm per hour
or m/s something like that a unit of
space divided by a unit of time and
that's not a coincidence speed is
defined as the change in location
divided by the amount of time that
change took in rigorous mathematical
terms that would be written like this x
stands for location T is time and each
of these D's just means a tiny change so
this is a tiny change in location
divided by a tiny passage of time if the
change in location is larger in the same
amount of time then the object is going
faster visually we represent that with a
longer Arrow so far this is all a bit
geometric though we need something
better for physics thankfully all the
way back in 1637 Renee deart invented
the coordinate system a mathematical
tool that turns geometry into algebra
it's such a powerful invention that we
named the most basic type after him
they're called cartisian coordinates for
his latinized name renatus cartesius
anyway coordinates allow us to write
things like velocity as an array of
numbers you just draw a few axes one for
each Dimension and then project your
velocity Arrow onto each of those
special axes those three values are
unique to that specific speed and
direction if the velocity changes then
those numbers change accordingly okay
sure but how does this apply to four
velocity time is just Dimension so it
gets an axis too we're used to thinking
of time as uniquely different from space
it's measured using clocks whereas space
is measured with rulers but over a
century ago we learned that space and
time are very similar not exactly the
same but similar so similar in fact that
we can visualize time the same way we do
space as a coordinate on an axis as time
passes everything is just moving forward
on the time axis think of it like the
perspective of some omniscient deity or
something but in our imaginations in
this four-dimensional space time a path
shows us everywhere an object will be
and when we can see everything it will
ever do within our ability to physically
predict that's why every point on a path
like this is called an event if we draw
tangent lines at each of those events we
know the four velocity will be along
those lines toward the future because
that's what velocities do why are the
lengths of all those arrows the same
though because of a weird Quirk of
reality say there's a space walking
astronaut and a rock since we see the
astronaut as stationary we know we're
using the astronaut's coordinates her
coordinates also include a clock which
measures coordinate time in this picture
but The Rock has its own clock which
measures its own passage of time its
proper time and if that rock is moving
relative to the astronaut then its clock
will take at a different rate this is
the four velocity of The Rock written in
the astronaut's coordinates this is the
spatial speed which is why it looks a
lot like the three-dimensional speed
from earlier this other one is the
temporal speed the speed through time
just like before this x still means
location but more specifically the
coordinate location as in the location
measured by the astronaut because that's
who the coordinates belong to the T is
time measured by the astronaut also
known as coordinate time this weird
looking te on the bottom is actually a
Greek tow which represents proper or
personal time as in the time measured by
The Rock when we're working with
four-dimensional SpaceTime we're working
with relativity things like time space
and velocity are all relative to The
Observer that's why we need two
different times in these equations one
is for the Rock and one is for the
astronaut why aren't there also two sets
of space coordinates because the rock
doesn't move in space according to the
Rock from The Rock's perspective the
astronaut is moving instead but that's
not the perspective we were looking from
our coordinates belong to the astronaut
time passes for both The Rock and the
astronaut but the Rock Only changes
location for the astronaut the bottom
tells us which object we're looking at
the top tells us who was looking from
there it's just a few more lines of math
I go through them in my book if you're
interested but I I think I can give you
a more intuitive understanding in this
video say we were to graph The Rock's
proper time against its coordinate
location that's time measured by the
Rock and space measured by the astronaut
this is super unconventional I I think
it'll help in this case but I would not
make a habit out of it had the rock been
sitting still its motion would be
directed along the time axis only it
would only be traveling through time but
she sees the rock moving you might think
the arrow would stretch to include a
change in location that's not what
happens though in relativity the faster
we see something moving the slower we
see its personal time pass the arrow
doesn't stretch it just turns any gain
in spatial speed is matched by a loss in
temporal speed no matter how fast an
object is going in Space the coordinates
conspire to keep the tip of the arrow on
this circle and therefore the length of
the arrow the same that length is the
speed of light well technically it's the
imaginary I multiplied by the speed of
light but close enough there's just one
problem this graphic only works for
spatial speeds less than the speed of
light at the speed of light the whole
thing breaks down remember when I said
this this is super unconventional I I
think it'll help in this case but I
would not make a habit out of it photons
move at exactly the speed of light
through space fast fast by this
reasoning it's lost all of its time
photons have no proper time they have no
anything for photons nothing exists
that's why we call their paths through
SpaceTime null paths every one of their
four-dimensional vectors including four
velocity is zero at all times you can
see how this doesn't really feel like a
speed even though it's defined the same
way so do we all travel at the speed of
light H kind of our four-dimensional
speed is the speed of light but that's
only true for matter not light and
that's probably not what people think of
when they hear the word speed if a
factoids sound simple it's probably at
least a little wrong that's why it's so
important to be diligent when you hear a
new piece of information especially when
dealing with current events ground news
is a great tool for anyone who wants a
more datadriven approach to their news
every story comes with a quick visual
breakdown of the political bias
factuality and ownership of the sources
reporting all backed by ratings from
three Independent News monitoring
organizations take the story about
interference in scientific research for
example right away you can see that 18
sources have reported on the story the
reports are entirely by Center and left
leaning sources which honestly isn't
that surprising for a science story but
I like being able to see the sources on
screen along with their lean you can see
the factuality ratings for each along
with their ownership breakdown in this
case 100% of the sources reporting on
this story are owned by media
conglomerates my favorite part is a
feature called my news bias which keeps
track of your reading habits over time
so that you can see and change your own
biases right now they're having a
holiday sale their biggest sale of the
Year through December 31st you'll get
40% off their Vantage plan that's
unlimited access to all of their
features including that my news bias I
mentioned earlier if you're interested
get ground news for just $5 per month by
going to ground. news/ science Asylum or
clicking the link in the description
below and until next time remember it's
okay to be a little
crazy there's no such thing as a uniform
gravitational field but while that's
technically true it's still useful to
discuss Earth's is approximately uniform
on human scales if you make your system
small enough any gravitational field can
be uniform and that drastically
simplifies the math anyway thanks for
watching